le courrier date du 20 juin 2020 une
demande de saisine du procureur de la
république de versailles formulée par
nicolas dainville candidats aux
élections municipales de la verrière ils
souhaitent vérifier la légalité d'un
fait concernant la maire sortante nelly
duthu l'occupation d'un logement
municipal à partir du 10 juillet 2015
on a mobilisé des juristes qui est ont
estimé qu'il n'avait aucune obligation
légale de la mairie d'accorder ce
logement à madame du tube et donc manade
du tu as eu un avantage elle a bénéficié
de cet appartement municipal alors
qu'ils n'avaient aucune obligation
légale à le faire dans tous les porte à
porte qu'on a fait il ya un grand
ras-le-bol face à ce que des citoyens
élus ou simples habitants qualifie de
copinage et c'est vrai que ces faits
m'ont été rapportés
cet argument il est vrai mais c'est un
moment important pour clarifier les
choses mises en cause nelly du tu as
décidé de nous répondre
une déclaration écrite lue par
visioconférence j'ai eu un logement de
fonction en septembre 2007 auquel
j'avais droit de par mon statut
d'institutrice exerçant sur la ville
quand j'ai obtenu le statut de
professeur des écoles j'ai payé un loyer
pour ce même logement en toute légalité
une fois mr après la décision de
monsieur de la démission pardon de
monsieur ajaj je tenais habiter à la
verrière je n'avais pas le droit au
logement social
j'ai donc cherché un logement dans le
privé que j'occupe depuis août 2010 8
voilà les faits et bien sûr là
au coeur de la république de versailles
avisera mais bien sûr monsieur d'un big
s'attaque à ma personne pour faire
oublier qu'il n'a pas de programme
global et cohérent dans l'intérêt de la
ville
la campagne se poursuit les électeurs de
la verrière sont appelés aux urnes ce
dimanche 28 juin